hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
match between paul charles murphy and
adolf andersen and we are currently in
game three so if you've been following
what's going on in the morphe saga so
far
uh the first match was won by anderson
and the second match ended in a draw
uh there were a couple of a couple of
good chances for anderson in that game
as well
but uh in the end he didn't he didn't
take his chance and now we are in game
three
that's uh much shorter than the previous
two games but
it's you know features a very very rare
moment in the match so it's a
a complete lapse of judgment maybe or or
maybe it was just uh
uh it seems like a blunder that should
not happen in a match of
well of this importance but uh you know
i'm very interested
in hearing what you guys uh think about
it so uh let's check it out
morphy has the white pieces again and i
thought he was gonna try
to go for e4 again and we'll try to get
his away
with anderson uh you know using the
evans gambit and everything since he
lost
uh the first game employing the evans
gambit uh but he doesn't he actually
goes for the rule opus so let's see now
how the game win with e4 by morphy
e5 knight to f3 knights to c6 and now
bishop to b5 going for the real opus
like
anderson did in the second game knight
to f6 anderson goes for the berlin
defense and
now d4 striking in the center right away
and now if you capture with the e pawn
then white has a lot of options he can
castle and then maybe go e5 and then you
know
black could run into some very
unpleasant positions but uh
instead uh anderson just captures on d4
with the knight we have knight captures
on d4 by morphy
and now e captures on d4 we have e5
now challenging the knight here and here
comes a move that uh
well uh he's really really interesting
here anderson can move the knights to e4
he can move the knight to d5 but he
actually plays
c6 so now they're trying to give up his
knight for the bishop on v5
and uh who has a great opinion about
this position where
it well it is our good friend um uh
johan yaakov luventhal as you know he's
been annotating a lot of the games that
morphe has been playing
uh still to prove that he is as good as
morphe and he says
c6 is is just a terrible move it's you
know absolute garbage
uh in his book he says that a weak move
ended the cause of of all subsequent uh
embarrassment
uh but uh you know suffice to say that
c6 is the strongest move recommended by
the engine so
again our good friend lauren thought uh
doesn't really really know what what
he's talking about but
uh uh you know such is the uh
such is the fate of everyone who
comments on chess there is always a
better engine at some point in time
and then you know it it will seem like
you had no idea what you were talking
about especially for that time
when they had no engines but okay c6 by
anderson and now morphy has to make a
choice uh whether to just
trade or to maybe go for something else
and morphe just castles here
uh and now now anderson should
definitely consider something like
knights to d5
and then morphy has to move the bishop
let's say bishop c4 knight c7 and then
the game continues we can develop
our dark square bishop castle play d6
uh and so on but here anderson captures
on b5 and uh
while c6 wasn't maybe that bad of an
idea capturing on b5 maybe is giving
morphe a bit too much because morphe
will not
capture on f6 morphe plays bishop to g5
uh and now he says um i i don't have to
capture and allow you rapid development
if i capture i'm gonna mess up your pawn
structure
and the problem is here if you try
something like h6 to drive away the
bishop
uh morphy has an instant win with rook
to e1 something low until actually got
right
now there's no no defending this uh if
you capture here then we just capture e
captures on f6 this is a discovered
check there's no defending this bishop
e7 we're gonna capture with the rook
and now after the key moves even upon
captures and g7 is completely winning if
king captures we're gonna play queen to
d4 with
check and now after king to f8 queen to
f6
and the problem is if black captures
here this is checkmate
and if you don't capture well not all
that much to play you can play rook h7
to kind of defend against
this checkmating idea uh but uh you know
it doesn't really help we just play rook
captures on f7 and then the queen
just hangs rook characters queen
captures here and the white is
completely winning
so after bishop to g5 we have bishop the
e7 by understanding okay you're welcome
to reclaim your piece
uh and now e captures on f6 and now
anderson has to decide whether to
capture with the bishop or with the pawn
uh both both moves have their merits but
the g captures on f6
maybe a bit more uh maybe a bit more
wild
since you you already have double deep
ones you have doubled b pawn and now
you're going to have doubled f pawn so
even if this is playable you do have the
bishop pair uh positionally black should
not be okay here but
again it's a it's a position where our
good friend yohanyako blewenthal
says that yeah this is bad because queen
captures on d4 is just winning for white
but queen captures on d4
actually equalizes the position for
black so queen to b6 for example
and the black is perfectly fine the
problem is even if you triple black's
pawns here you have to move the bishop
the bishop moves and now after a move
like b4 now
this end game is not a problem for black
with the queens
of the board uh you you have the bishop
pair you're gonna play d5 develop your
light square bishop and the rooks
already have nicely opened files
semi open files um so it's gonna be very
very much playable for black
uh but okay uh anderson obviously uh
does not agree with that so he plays
bishop captures on f6 instead instead of
g captures
and now rook the e1 checked by morphy so
the king has to move
uh castling is no longer allowed and now
bishop captures on f6 we have queen
captures on f6 and now
uh morphe plays c3 if you try something
like queen e2 to deliver checkmate g6 is
uh
sufficient for black to eliminate uh any
any and all
threats uh so after queen captures on f6
we have c3
uh morphe is trying to give up uh you
know a a little bit more
uh here not not give up it's he's
basically trying to trade us off to get
a nice uh
developing move with the knight in but
anderson of course not about to allow it
he plays d5 and he wants to develop his
own pieces
so c captures on d4 morphe wins the pawn
now and the bishop to e6 now
uh we have knight to c3 and a6 now
defending the b5 pawn
and now morphy has to figure out how to
how to play this well
uh there is no more dark square bishop
from black so there's only a light
square bishop the e5 square is uh
free for grabs so he plays a rook to e5
now there's a double attack on the d5
pawn
uh queen to b3 is coming so you can
attack it three times
the other rook is coming to d1 so uh you
know or
e1 is just going to be a very nice
position for white and the black still
has to decide how to
activate this rook and more importantly
how to activate this rook
probably g6 king g7 and then bringing
the rook into the game but that's three
moves and you know you don't really have
that
now you could allow this if anderson
really wanted to develop he should give
up the pawn he should play something
like h6
right away and if knight captures on d5
okay we're gonna capture bishop captures
on the five rook captures
and then we're gonna play g6 play king
to g7 bring the rook in and we're gonna
have a
well a nice grip on the d4 pawn
regardless of uh
of just losing our own d5 pawn but okay
after rook to e5 anderson decides to
defend it would rook to d8 he says okay
there's still time
g6 king g7 the other were coming into
the game but now
queen to b3 morphy adds another attacker
and now
queen to e7 this is a very cool trap by
anderson just showing how
how uh impressive of a player he is
because if morphe
was eager to grab this pawn with knight
captures on the e5
then comes queen to d6 uh now with it
with a triple attack on the knight
and then best for morphe is probably
queen before just trying to trade queens
now he plays bishop captures on d5 we're
gonna play rook captures on d5 and now
uh queen captures here on b4 so uh
winning winning the queen like this
and even giving up the two rooks for
example rook captures with checking the
seven rook captures here but now
we're gonna capture on b2 attack the
rook and after rook to d1 capture the a2
pawn
and now morphy would have two rooks and
the pass pawn against the queen but
the the queen side majority here not
majority the the queen side
the three pawns on the queen side uh
would be too much for the
for more of his rooks to stop so he
doesn't go for that after queen to e7
although knight captures on d5 very
interesting morphy just brings the other
rook into the attack as well now doubles
up on the e file
and now g5 by anderson saying i'm not
here to defend i'm here to attack i'm
gonna play h4
and then you know just uh get my pawns
in front of your king
so now morphy has to decide how to go
about this uh he first plays queen to d1
he wants to play queen to d2 and didn't
put pressure on the g5
square and now if anderson was eager to
continue the attack let's say he goes h5
then queen to d2
we attack the pawn and if rook the g8
defending now we play h4
and now after g4 we have this queen to
h6 check and white wins that's the
problem yeah because now
uh if you block well if you move the
king then this is just winning rook
captures captures and rook captures wins
the queen
and if you don't move the king if you
block with rook to g7
again it's not a problem just rook to g5
and there's no defending this
uh if f6 uh trying to get the queen to
help out with the defense now
rook captures on e6 is just winning uh
queen captures rogue captures on g7 and
well that's a game over so instead after
queen to d1 we have queen to f6 by
anderson
and now morphy has to figure out a game
plan whether he wants to play some like
queen d2 as planned going after the g5
fund and probably anderson defends with
h6 and then the game continues
uh or he wants to play knights the e to
maybe bring the knight over to g3 maybe
to h5
later on in the game uh morphy does none
of that morphy just plays
the other rook rook rookie one to e3
uh and now prepares rook to f3 to
challenge
anderson's queen here and there is only
one good move for anderson here
uh well two moves rook to d6 is also
playable but king the g7 is just the
best uh came to g7 for a very good
reason
uh because uh well i'm not gonna tell
you why
uh because uh uh you're gonna figure out
the the pause the video moment too
easily if i tell you why king to g7 is
essential here
uh but uh just to show you what happened
rook the g8 was played instead okay now
you have very nice control of this uh
g pawn but there's a problem rook the g8
completely
blunders the position he probably had
some plans of maybe playing king the e7
then rook here rook here
the other rook coming to jade maybe even
doubling up maybe some
uh rook coming into the attack here who
knows what he had in mind but he
completely overlooked one
a very important move from morphe so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for morphe while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting it
it's not
difficult to spot once you know it's
there much
you know like all things in life but for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's a
rook captures on e6 of course that's
what we play and now you understand why
king the g7 was essential
uh because now well he was uh in this
position on move 20
yes we are still in move 20 that otto
thunderson resigned the game
and morphe equalizes the match by
winning the third game so now anderson
wins the first one second is a draw and
morphe wins the third one
uh there's nothing to be done here if
you capture here than just rook f3
uh wins the queen that's why it'd be
much better if the king was on g7 so no
such move would be possible
and if you don't capture the rook well
there's nothing to play i mean uh you
could try some like queen to g7 and say
okay i'll try and you know play anything
being down a piece but
uh understand is to to great a gentleman
to even attempt something like this
uh and the waste uh morphy's time like
this so
after rook the g8 uh really um
uh uh sorry not after rook to jade after
rook captures on e6
a tough blow for anderson who played a
really spectacular match so far and this
one move now equalizes the match in
morphy's favor
and we'll see what happens uh later on
in the match but so far
uh uh mor morphy was struggling in the
first game a lot in the second game
somewhat but now in the third game
it seemed that he got the the upper hand
uh i did uh some reading and
supposedly he knew the chess theory from
max lange about
this entire opening up until the move 12
but
this is not the this has not been
confirmed uh
some some some say that morphe knew a
theory about this
up until the move 12 then that anderson
didn't other say that there is no
you know evidence of this so we will
never know
uh but it was played very impressively
and you know black um
uh black got into some trouble but he
equalized very easily and very early on
and uh i think my favorite part of the
game was uh you know 11th house
comment about this c6 move that it's uh
a weak move and
the cause of all subsequent
embarrassment when it is in fact the
strongest move recommended by the engine
and in honor of your hanyako blue intel
our good friend i'm
going to use this as uh well the the a
part of the thumbnail
so uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh and uh
you know uh uh you're continuing to
enjoy the morphe saga uh it's not going
anywhere there are still plenty
of games to show to be shown uh i would
like to thank pedro felix
tiana nominee uh benjamin wilson john
lockwood and david kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day